seven men are trying to become iran's
eighth president
the presidential elections due to take
place on june 18th
now the moderate candidate abdul nasir
hamati who is the former head of iran
central bank
has been running on the campaign promise
of trying to fix
iran's failing economy as a result of
crippling u.s sanctions
since the united states withdrew from
the nuclear deal in 2018
hassan rouhani took office eight years
ago and since then the economy has
really
plummeted in this country the
unemployment rate is at an
all-time high the real has lost over 80
percent of its value
that is where the moderate candidate is
really focusing his attention
to try and convince voters to vote for
him because he
has the expertise the financial
background to try and fix the country's
economy
meanwhile the frontrunner in the race is
the conservative candidate ibrahim raisi
who is currently the head of iran's
judiciary now
ibrahim raisi has been really the front
runner because we've seen
the support of the establishment very
much behind him
he was appointed to the head of the
judiciary by the supreme leader aita
ali khamenei and he is still in that
position if he becomes president he will
resign from that
post his promises has been that he will
continue negotiations in vienna
to try and reach an agreement to the
nuclear deal and try to keep that going
he ran in 2017 against president hassan
rouhani he managed to get nearly 16
million votes
but lost to the president at that time
voter turnout is of high importance to
the establishment here the lowest voter
turnout they had
in this country since the revolution of
1979
was around 50 percent and that was in
the presidential elections of 1993.
there is a sense that the people are
very much disillusioned with
the governments that they vote for a lot
of people i've spoken to in the capital
explained that they just can't be
bothered to vote this time because they
don't see much difference in the
policies
of the various candidates the main point
of contention has been that
the moderates and the conservatives that
they've had in government over the past
few years
haven't really made much of a difference
in the day-to-day lives of the people
and that is because
iran's foreign policy is not decided at
the level of the government it is
decided at the level
of the system and therefore it is not
really up to
a president how the country will have
its interactions with the outside world
that is decided on a much broader
and higher level for now the system is
encouraging people to vote
that it is their moral duty it is the
duty of every iranian to come out on
june 18th
but there is a sense that any kind of a
turnout over 40
will be seen as a victory for this
system